[Applause]
I said I'm a alaikum I wanted to briefly
just touch upon this recent incident
that happened in Norway where you had
these anti-muslim anti-islam uneducated
ignorant individuals getting together to
provoke Muslims to try to propagate hate
by getting together and burning the
verbatim word of God Almighty the Koran
so we know that these things are gonna
continue to happen but now how we
respond to them if every time a trap is
set and these are traps set how are we
gonna go about dealing with these things
are we our our response is going to be
fruitful are they going to produce fruit
results so we have an individual that I
would talk to as if I'm talking to my
son and many people are lifting him up
as some hero of the Quran but I wouldn't
consider my own son who I'm trying to
raise in the Dean who are gonna be
inshallah warriors in the Dean who have
good Adam good character alack we want
all of our children to be true
ambassadors to this Deen but if if he
ran out and he tried to throw some kick
and punch and then you have all of this
escalating and then other people getting
involved you see this other brother
arguing with police and drama a big
drama show what's the benefit at the end
I would tell my own son I say what are
you doing son did I raised you better
than that
how are you benefiting Islam how are you
benefitting benefiting the Ummah what's
the next guy gonna come with a bottle a
knife a bat we know how this goes we
know this violence just escalates we got
too many of those we got too many
people with zeal they have this they
bring this hood stuff they bring this
street mentality they bring this zeal
but it has to be based on knowledge so I
would tell my son son this is not the
way forward for anybody it's not going
to produce anything good
it's like coca-cola everybody's all
excited for a moment the guys watching
too many autos and thinking we're at
that time and now what have you done the
fizz from the coca-cola is gone you got
a sugar rush rush what are you left with
diabetes what are you left with you keep
drinking that garbage and what are we
left with if we got all we got is people
but just feeding into the stereotype
that Muslims are violent so brothers and
sisters don't fall into these traps use
the zeal and this energy to really
benefit the Ummah learn your Deen make
sure you're waking up for fudger make
sure you're hitting the books that
you're understanding the basics of Islam
you staying away from the clubs you're
not following your desires and Allah
didn't tell you to defend the Deen this
way get out there intellectually convey
this message live it having the good ed
up the good a flack that people can see
you are true ambassador to Islam that
you're representing it with good
character good morality and then you're
calling people to what a lost want Allah
to the Creator a God Almighty told you
to call them too and I believe in Norway
you have projects underway and I believe
in Norway there's a group called Islam
net they're trying to open up a good
center where people can come learn about
their purpose in life where they clear
the misconceptions about Islam this
brother should go hook up with them and
intellectually combat
these evil these these are deluded
people who've been affected by the hate
and the violence is not going to solve
or eliminate their hate it would just
continue to perpetuate more hate against
Muslims in Islam and feed the
stereotypes that Muslims are violent
look at them now we need to battle these
things intellectually you need to get
educated on your Deen and deal with
these things that academic intellectual
level and if you don't know go and know
and go and find out and then back to
people like for instance Islam net doing
some great work go and be a part if
you're in Norway there in Norway support
their work and save the our total Ghazi
stuff for the big screen
brothers and sisters and if you want to
learn how to fight go join a martial
arts class under some supervision learn
how to properly throw a kick a punch but
at the same time you're gonna learn some
discipline and a true fighter true
warrior has that discipline and he knows
when it's time to defend himself and
when to use it and step up be a real man
alright and as the Prophet Solo Salaam
had told us that the strong person is
the one who can control themselves
control their emotions their desires
that's a true warrior at the same time
he knows when to step up and be a man
and to defend himself and his family so
this is just my thoughts brothers and
sisters Thank You jazakallah hiram
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh